good evening everyone
thank you for joining us on this
historic day
it's an honor to be here with all of you
when the president asked me to serve in
this role
we talked about the importance of
bringing truth and transparency
back to the briefing room and he asked
me to ensure
we are communicating about the policies
across the biden harris administration
and the work his team is doing every
single day on behalf of all american
people
there will be times when we see things
differently in this room i mean among
all of us
that's okay that's part of our democracy
and rebuilding trust with the american
people
will be central to our focus in the
press office and in the white house
every single day so we had a very busy
and active day
today as you all know but i wanted to
take a moment to
go through the 15 executive actions or
highlights of them i should say and some
of the age the
the steps that the president asked
agencies to take today
you should have all received copies of
the executive orders as well as the
accompanying fact sheets
but i want to take this moment to
highlight them for the american public
who are watching at home to combat the
deadly virus the president launched his
100 day masking challenge
asking americans to do their part and
mask up
for 100 days he's doing his part as well
issuing a mask
mandate that will require anyone
visiting a federal building
or federal land or using certain modes
of public transportation to wear a mask
he signed an executive order reversing
trump's decision to withdraw from the
world health organization
this will strengthen our own efforts to
get the pandemic under control
by improving global health and tomorrow
we're not wasting any time
dr fauci will participate remotely in
the meeting of the world health
organization
as the u.s head of delegation president
biden also
officially appointed a covid 19 response
coordinator
a position and team we had already
previously announced
but made it official today to create a
unified national response to the
pandemic
and he reestablished the national
security team responsible
for global health security and bio
defense
the coven 19 pandemic has triggered an
almost unprecedented
housing affordability crisis he took
immediate action to confront the crisis
and asked relevant agencies to extend
nationwide moratoriums on evictions
and foreclosures the pandemic has also
increased the hardship on millions of
americans
who owe federal student loans in
response the president asked the
department of education
to extend the pause on student loan
payments and interest
he rejoined the paris climate agreement
putting the united states
back in a position to exercise global
leadership
and advancing the objectives of the
ambitious agreement
sorry i hope you're comfortable there's
a few more
and a second broad executive order will
roll back harmful regulatory reversals
made by the previous
administration to protect public health
and the environment
this order protects our nation's
treasures by re reviewing the boundaries
for several national monuments
places a temporary moratorium on all oil
and natural gas leasing in the arctic
national wildlife refuge and
re-establishes the inter-agency working
group on the social cost of greenhouse
gases
he also launched a whole-of-government
effort to advance
racial equity and root out systemic
racism
from federal programs and institutions
he directed the secretary of homeland
security
in consultation with the attorney
general to take all appropriate actions
to preserve and fortify
daca which provides temporary relief
from deportation to dreamers
young people who are brought to this
country as children
the president also put an end to the
muslim ban of policy rooted in religious
animus and xenophobia
he signed a proclamation effective
immediately
halting further funding or construction
of the previous administration's
border wall and terminating the
so-called national emergency used to
wastefully divert
billions for wall construction also
today
president biden sent an
immigration bill to congress the u.s
citizenship act modernizes our
immigration system
it provides hard-working people who have
enriched our communities and lived here
for decades an opportunity to earn
citizenship
the president's priority reflected in
the bill are to
responsibly manage the border keep
families together
grow our economy address the root causes
of migration from central america
and ensure that america can remain a
refuge for those fleeing
prosecution with that i'd love to take
your questions zeke why don't you kick
us off
thanks again first off congratulations
and uh one question about your role you
touched on this a little bit of the
topic
when you were up there do you see
yourself at your primary roles for
promoting the interests of the president
or are you there to provide
us the unvarnished truth so that we can
share that with the american people
well let me first say zeke that i come
to this podium
having served both in the white house
and at the state department
as the spokesperson there and i traveled
the world on trips to promote democracy
where i saw the power of the united
states and of course the power of this
podium
uh and the power of truth and the
importance of setting an example of
engagement
and transparency so i will just state
because you gave me the opportunity i
have
deep respect for the role of a free and
independent press in our democracy and
for the role
all of you play as i noted earlier there
will be moments when we disagree
and there will certainly be days where
we disagree uh
for extensive parts of the briefing even
perhaps but we have a common goal
which is sharing accurate information
with the american people if the
president were standing here with me
today
he would say he works for the american
people
i work for him so i also work for the
american people
but his objective and his commitment is
to bring transparency and truth
back to government to share the truth
even when it's hard to hear
um and uh that's something that i hope
to deliver on in this role as well
and then just one uh subject of once and
over short on time um
when will uh president biden begin uh
making some foreign legal calls who's on
that initial list and
during the transition he didn't speak
with president putin
uh does he plan on doing that and is he
going to discuss
retaliation for the solar winds hack on
federal government
sure um let me try to get to those and
i'll just note since zeke mentioned it i
know some of you have been to another
event this evening because we're not
fully done with the day
so we will have longer briefings in the
future but we'll try to get to as many
questions as possible
so his first call foreign leader call
will be on friday with prime minister
trudeau
i expect they will certainly discuss um
the important relationship with canada
uh as well as uh his decision on the
keystone pipeline
that we announced today uh he i don't
have any plans or any uh plans to read
out for you in terms of a call with
president putin i will note for you that
i would expect
his early calls will be with partners
and allies
he feels it's important to rebuild those
relationships and to address
the challenges and threats we're facing
in the world on solar winds we've spoken
with this
about this previously a bit prior to his
inauguration i should say today
we are of course we reserve the right to
respond
at a time in a manner of our choosing to
any cyber attack
but our team is of course just getting
on the ground today they're just getting
onto their computers
so i don't have anything to read out for
you or to
preview for you at this point in time
peter go ahead jeff
let me i have a question for you on
policy first a quick housekeeping
question a short time ago president
biden said that he received a very
generous letter from president trump of
course he said it was
private he said i will not talk about it
until i talk to him is president biden
planning
to call now former president trump and
is this white house working in any way
to try to put the two in touch
well i think peter that was a reflection
of uh president biden's view and i was
with him when he was reading
the letter in the oval office right
before he signed the executive actions
was that this is a letter that was
private as he said to you all
it was both generous and gracious
and it was just a reflection of him not
planning to release the letter
unilaterally but
i wouldn't take it as an indication of a
pending call with
the former president let me ask you on
policy if i can quickly you talk
obviously your role is sort of uh in
terms of delivering the best information
to the american people on behalf of this
white house
the battle for truth may be as tough a
fight right now as is
the battle against coronavirus how do
you and president biden plan to combat
disinformation that in many ways led to
that assault we witnessed two weeks ago
today
on the capitol well i think peter
um there are a number of ways to combat
misinformation one of them
is accurate information and truth and
data and
um and sharing information even when it
is hard to hear
and even when um it um is not
meeting the expectations of of people at
home who are desperate for this crisis
to be over
um we'll have more to share with you um
in the next few days hopefully before
the weekend but
uh what we plan to do is not just return
these daily briefings monday
through friday not saturdays and sundays
i'm not a monster but uh
on but also to return briefings with our
health officials and public health
officials we want to do those
regularly in a dependable way
with data shared with all of you and
with the public so that
they can also track progress we're
making on getting the pandemic under
control as it relates to the candidate
if i can quickly uh we know president
biden's beginning without a single
member of his cabinet
confirmed what is your understanding on
how quickly those confirmations will
happen and when should we expect
additional nominations and
ambassadorships to be announced
well peter the desire to get his cabinet
in place and get his team confirmed is
front and center for the president he it
is an issue a topic he discussed with
members of congress from both the
republican and democratic party today
during the course of the day in the
course of events i think as we were
coming out here
avril haynes should be on her way to
confirmation i don't know if it's
officially voted
been happened yet but she's on her way
we have prioritized
getting our national security team in
place given the crisis we're facing
given the importance of keeping the
american people safe
at this time but we are eager for those
to move forward quickly
in the coming days ideally tomorrow by
friday
we'd like to move them quickly it's
something that he is raising in his
conversations as we all are with members
of congress and their team
thank you thank you karen jen has
president biden invited congressional
leaders to sit down and talk about the
covenant relief measure that he
introduced
uh well he has been discussing uh the
coveted relief measures the entire
package that has as you know
unemployment insurance it has relief and
assistance for the american people
it also has money to reopen schools
which i know as a mother impacts all of
us uh
but he has been discussing that with
democrats and republicans since long
before
he was sworn in today today was a day
where he had conversations about working
together
in terms of getting his team in place on
his agenda moving forward
but i expect he will be picking up the
phone in the coming days and having more
of those conversations
in terms of when he will meet in person
uh i will say
soon and we hope to have more of an
update on that for you soon as well do
you expect him to play in those
negotiations there was a lot of comments
today about his familiarity with the
senate
how involved will he be in that process
he will be quite involved there is the
issue that he wakes up every day focused
on
is getting the pandemic under control
the issue he goes to bed
every night focused on is getting the
pandemic under control
this package is a pivotal step to doing
that
and it has assistance uh for the
american people to
make that bridge financially it also has
uh in essential funding for vaccine
distribution
he will be very involved he will not be
the only one we have a whole team here
of senior staff of course but
as you noted he is not a stranger to the
senate he served there for 36 years
many of these people he has many of the
members on both sides of the aisle he
served with
over that time and i expect he will be
quite involved in the process
go ahead jen so
on on this coveted relief package
senator romney was already saying to
reporters today that he doesn't see a
need for another virus relief package
and he's the kind of republican vote
you're likely going to be trying to get
so how long are you willing to try to
work
to get republican support before you
decide to go through the budget
reconciliation
process instead well uh as
you know because you all cover it and as
i have stated a couple times here today
we are in the middle
of an urgent crisis in this country it's
not just impacting
democrats it's impacting republicans
it's impacting red states and blue
states
and this plan is intended to address the
suffering of the american people so we
hope and and frankly we expect
republicans in congress and democrats
too
will support assistance that will bring
relief to the people they represent
this is a conversation he of course gave
a prime time address as you all know
last week it seems like a long time ago
but it wasn't
uh to announce his specifics and he has
already had a number of conversations
with democrats and the republicans
those will continue his clear preference
is to move forward with a bipartisan
bill there's no question about it
but we're also not going to take any
tools off the table for how the senate
house and senate can get this urgent
package done so
we are only less than a day has he been
president of the united states but uh he
is going to continue to work with
members of both parties to get it done
francesca go ahead thank you jen i do
have a question about reopening schools
but i just want to
pick up where she left off on that and
note that republicans including
lindsey graham who's expected to be the
senate budget committee
ranking member have already said that
the price tag on the president's
proposal is too high for them so is
there any wiggle room
on that number and has he already begun
negotiations with mitch mcconnell
well uh first the package wasn't
designed
uh with the number 1.9 trillion as a
starting point it was designed with the
components that were necessary to give
people the relief they needed
so what's challenging is what are you
going to cut
are you going to cut funding for
vaccinations are you going to cut
funding for unemployment insurance are
you going to cut funding for
reopening schools but it was laid out as
his proposal based on recommendations
from
economists recommendations from health
experts and
as you've also seen there have been uh
also an outpouring of support from
everyone from bernie sanders to the
chamber of commerce for the package and
the components in it
but this is a discussion it's a
conversation
and uh he is no stranger to the process
of bill making
so we're at the beginning of the process
and and as we continue
there'll be conversations with members
of both parties of what will be in a
final package and rarely does it look
exactly like
the initial package that is proposed
with regards to reopening schools
what level of vaccination in teachers or
students or level of testing
does the administration think would be
appropriate in order to meet the target
date that the president has set
this is a great question and as i noted
at the banning as a mom myself i
want to know all the details as well
we're going to have more to share
from our health experts in the coming
days
and i will venture to get them in here
to give you all a briefing on the
specifics but we really want to
lean into them on their expertise on
that front go ahead
i'll come right to you right next go
ahead uh so president biden
a promise to end all new oil and gas
leasing on federal lands when he was a
candidate the
order that you just mentioned that he
signed today was much narrower than that
it's a temporary moratorium and it only
applies to anwar
and there's some debate about whether he
has the legal flexibility to even follow
through with his full promise
does the administration still have that
commitment today to
uh the leases will be uh reviewed by our
team
uh we just have only been in office for
less than a day now
uh and i will just since you gave me the
opportunity just also confirm for all of
you
all of our executive actions that we
released today were reviewed by the
career staff at the olc
we went through that process in advance
of releasing them
that took a great deal of work from our
policy teams but
that was a vital part of the process for
us as well talk a little bit just about
the kind of the preparations for getting
the the white house ready
uh and safe for the the president the
new president
it's been reported that you did the 500
000 worth of deep cleaning could you
talk about the measures that you took
to ensure that the president is safe
well the i would refer you to the
general services administration who
oversees any steps like that
what i can speak to if it's of interest
of the steps we're all taking
to make sure that we are safe he is safe
you are all
safe those include daily testing when
we're in the white house it includes
wearing n95 masks i wore it out of
course here today
and we'll continue to do that it
includes stringent rules about
social distancing um and abiding by that
in the building uh that keeps us safe
but
we're also the president has asked us to
also be models to the american people
and that's vitally important to us
as well so there are a number of new
coveted steps precautions that we've put
in place as of today
go ahead all the way in the back thank
you so much jen thanks for doing
this in a daily basis again so climate
change being one of the priorities
how does president biden plan to work
with brazil
during the campaign by the criticized
brazil on deforestation
and then the brazilian president
criticized by them back
and he was the last one to congratulate
president biden on his election what is
the expectation for
uh their relationship and does he plan
to speak
with the brazilian president uh well i
don't have anything
uh to predict for you or or advance for
you
in terms of a call or conversation what
i can convey
on climate change of course and
addressing the climate crisis it's one
of the four crises that
he's identified will impact his
administration is impacting not just the
american people but the global community
is that rejoining the paris climate
agreement is a vital step
toward doing that the united states was
one of the only countries in the world
as you all know that was
has not been has not had a seat at the
table in the last
few years a little technical step there
is
we have submitted that to the u.n
secretary general and it will take
approximately 30 days for that to take
place but
i use that as an example because that's
one step but we also know that we need
to be models here at home
as we are addressing an issue like this
the united states continues to be one of
the world's largest emitters
of greenhouse gases and we need to put
in place policies
and take steps here to address that as
well but i'm sure we'll have more to
discuss on brazil
in the coming months go ahead right
there what are the next steps when it
comes to
iran and does the president have any
plans to rejoin the nuclear deal
well the president has al has made clear
that he believes that through follow-on
diplomacy the united states should seek
to lengthen and strengthen
nuclear constraints on iran and address
other issues
of concern iran must resume compliance
with significant nuclear
constraints under the deal in order
for that to proceed i will say that as i
noted a little bit earlier
we would expect that some of his earlier
conversations
with foreign counterparts or foreign
leaders will be with partners and allies
um and that we would certainly
anticipate that this would be part of
the discussion
and then could you just give us some
color about what it was like for him
going into the oval office he's been
waiting for this for so long what was
his reaction
well uh you know i spent a little time
with him earlier and
he uh had an incredible sense of calm
um uh and he uh and a sense of
some joy uh of course he spent the day
with his family and his grandchildren
and his children and
that always has an impact i think but
you know he also said he felt like he
was coming home
remember he spent eight years here as
the vice president uh playing
an important role as a partner to
president obama
and um you know that was the emotion
that overtook him today
uh he's also eager to get to work he was
asking questions about
policy and covid and what's next and um
so
uh you know that also reflects his
desire to roll up his sleeves and and
get going
uh let's see i'm sorry i told you i was
gonna ask you i just skipped over here
go ahead i'll take it now uh so if
president biden wants
a theme of his presidency to be unifying
the country does he think
that nancy pelosi and chuck schumer
should drop a potentially
divisive senate impeachment trial
well he spoke today as you all saw
about unity in his inaugural address and
the importance of
unity in bringing the country together
and the resolve of the american people
in helping to get through this moment
you know we are confident though that
um just like the american people can the
senate can also
multitask and they can do their
constitutional duty while continuing to
conduct the business of the american
people
and his view is that the way to bring
the country together is to address the
problems we're facing
and so that means getting this coveted
relief package through having democrats
and republicans take a serious look at
that and have
conversations with each other about how
to move it forward and he's going to
leave the mechanics the timing and the
specifics
of how congress moves forward on
impeachment to them and
a quick follow-up on president trump's
inauguration day
he filed paperwork to run for
re-election same day
does president biden have any plans to
do that today
late or in the coming days i will say
having talked to him today his
his focus is not on politics it is on
uh getting to work and solving the
problems of the american people
uh so and as he noted or
on the campaign he will wait until uh
sometime
into his first term to speak more about
his uh political plans moving forward
go ahead yeah thank you jen the
president pledged today to repair
alliances
has he planned his first foreign trip
yet well we're only
seven hours in here you're ready for the
foreign trip um
i'm ready too uh i don't have any
details on a foreign trip to
lay out for you at this point in time
hopefully we will at some point in time
go ahead all the way in the back
yeah hi uh congratulations on your new
position uh owen jensen with ewtn global
catholic network
two big concerns for pro-life america
the hyde amendment
which of course keeps
tax payer dollars as you know from
paying for abortions medicaid abortions
and the mexico city policy which under
the previous administration
expanded to keep tax dollars from
overseas paying for abortions
so what are president what is president
biden planning on doing in those two
items right now
uh well i think we'll have more to say
on the mexico city policy in the coming
days um but i will just take the
opportunity to
remind all of you that he is a devout
catholic and somebody who
attends church regularly uh he started
his day attending church with his family
this morning
but i don't have anything more for you
on that go ahead yeah
as president elect he talked about the
possibilities of
using the defense production act to ramp
up the production of vaccines
having looked at more data does he still
feel that's necessary was that included
for example in anything that you signed
today uh we'll stay tuned
we'll do this again tomorrow and there
may be more specifics to share on plans
on covet tomorrow i expect there will be
including more details on the defense
production act he absolutely
remains committed to invoking the
defense production act
in order to get the supply
and the materials needed to get the
vaccine out to
americans across the country and remains
committed to his goal of
getting 100 million shots in the arms of
americans in the first hundred days
go ahead thank you very much um
the president talked movingly about
unity today
and i've heard from people who say well
that's just talk they want to know what
action they're going to see
to show that kind of unity can you i
mean peter mentioned
impeachment can you can you tell us what
kind of action we can expect to see
that will assure people that he wants to
reach out to people who voted for him
and people who did not
sure um well first i think anybody who
has covered
president biden for some time or worked
for him or
spent time with him knows that he is
somebody who
always sees the optimistic side of
working with people who may disagree
with him
people across the aisle and that has
long been his
uh commitment and desire through his
many decades in public service
so his own history tells you how
committed he is
but you know part of it is his words
which he shared today with the american
public on
quite a big stage also his actions he
has reached out to
not just democratic members of congress
but also republicans not just democratic
governors but also republicans not just
democratic mayors but also republicans
and he said today in his speech the
biggest platform
most presidents have through the course
of their presidency that he will govern
for all americans
and uh you know that of course has to be
backed up by actions uh as you conveyed
but
uh he's going to uh venture to um
uh do that in in every policy he pursues
um every engagement he has because he
feels if we can come together we'll be a
stronger country
go ahead jen will be seeing a death
penalty moratorium under this
administration
uh the president uh as you know has
stated his opposition to the death
penalty
uh in the past uh he remains that
remains his view uh
i don't have anything more uh for you in
terms of future actions or
uh mechanisms though i can i'll circle
back if there's more i can share with
you
on a lighter note will he keep donald
trump's air force one color scheme
change
this is such a good question i have not
had the opportunity to dig into that
today
given the number of executive actions
orders the inauguration
a few things happening i will venture to
get you an answer on that and maybe we
can talk about it in here tomorrow
i'm judging more people important
letting you know i just followed the
peter's question does
president uh president biden believe
that president trump needs to be held
accountable for the capital insurrection
a couple of weeks ago and does that
accountability
require that president trump be barred
from holding
future federal office well um zeke
you know he uh has spoken very firmly
and uh fiercely publicly about his views
of the horrific events on the horrific
events on january 6th
and uh he has also of course spoken with
members of congress about that
as you all know but he is going to leave
it to
members of congress to
carry out their constitutional duty and
determine what the path forward is
and what the mechanisms are going to be
what the process will be and what the
timeline will be
and certainly he ran against
donald trump because he did not think he
was fit to serve in office
long before the events of january 6. he
is here today because he decided to run
against him
but we're focusing on moving forward
we're focusing on addressing the
the issues facing the american public uh
and as you know
uh that means we're focused on our covet
package go ahead if i can follow up on
that a little bit jen is the president
being updated first of all the progress
of the fbi investigation and we know the
fbi is leading the investigation into
the assault
on the capitol does president biden have
confidence in fbi director ray
well peter as you noted there's an
ongoing investigation which we certainly
support
i'm not sure that he has received an
update today on anything about the
investigation but
we certainly support those ongoing and
we will
i'm sure be receiving updates in the
days ahead of confidence in the fbi
director
i think i have not spoken with him about
specifically fbi director
ray in recent days uh peter but i'll
circle back with you if there's more to
convey
the president did not mention the word
trump in his inaugural address today
what was the intention behind not making
any
direct reference to his predecessor in
that speech
well i think the intention was to make
the speech not about
any individual elected official any
current
president former president but make it
about the american people
and the moment we're facing in history
uh right now the
the um struggles that millions of
americans are facing uh who don't have
jobs
uh the fear people have about the health
of
uh their grandparents and their cousins
and their brothers
um and to make it more about um the
strength of the american people when
they come together
and not about any individual but as
as you saw in his speech it was
forward-looking it was not meant to look
back on the past
go ahead how does president uh madden
plan to recover the
united states image around the world
and what is his priority globally
well his priority is first rebuilding
our partnerships and alliances around
the world and regaining
america's seat at the global table and
you can see that as evidenced in his
rejoining the paris climate agreement
rejoining the world health organization
his plans to engage with partners and
allies and
work together to address many of the
threats and issues we're facing around
the world
but i think that is what you will see as
his focus in the weeks ahead
thank you thank you everyone let's do
this again tomorrow
you